62% Vinnie I'm coming to this one with
you 62% of small business owners earned
Less in Q4
2023 than Q4 2022 this is a Zero Hedge
story let me say it again 62% of small
business owners made less money in Q4
2023 than they did in 2024 a December
small business revenue report by
alignable reveals that 62% of small
business owners experience a decline of
Revenue during Q4 2023 compared to last
quarter this figure is notably higher
than 52% who had previously anticipated
a disappointing Ford quarter the primary
concern amongst small business owners
has shifted to ramping up Revenue
overtaking worries related to inflation
approximately 37% of those surveyed now
engage in side jobs to wow that is
insane small business owners 37% are now
engaging in side jobs Uber to supplement
their income while an additional 56%
take on side gigs to cover mounting
expenses leaving only 7% satisfied with
the income generated solely from their
business damn small business owners
continue to Grapple with the
challenges of high interest rates
affecting 52% of them moreover 41% of
small business owner renters reported
being unable to pay their rent in full
and on time in December while 51% faced
rent increases Tom the this is not this
is these are real numbers with small
business owners facing these guys are
running companies and they're getting
jobs on the side so I I I just called
the White House and they said the the
econom is fine and they hung up on me
that case okay then let's skip the story
and go to the next no so here's what's
going on we all talked about this and
this and we said that the fourth quarter
was probably not going to be as good as
the third quarter because Americans
dipped into helocs they ran their credit
cards up to a trillion dollars and they
said oh the consumer was resilient
resilient well guess what we're hearing
we're hearing that Q4 was not the barn
burner that Q3 was and now small
business people are hurting we said Main
Street is going to hurt this is the
economy coming home to roost and this is
uh consumer spending down in fourth
quarter and this is the small businesses
are not worried about the inflation now
they're worried about raising their
revenue and they had a decline in
Revenue in Q4 23 versus 22 what declin
consumer spending and so this is exactly
what we talked about the that that
underneath the headlines for wow look at
the S&P 500 Oh you mean the S&P 7 The
Magnificent 7 and Nidia chips that
freaking drove that engine all year you
mean that underneath it the economy is
not in great shape and interest rates
are high and going to be here for a
while and this just shows that um below
the surface people are still having a
tough time despite the headlines how by
the way yeah go ah go ahead Adam because
I was say this is egregious I I want to
use a big word I just want to take a
second to just say how much I
appreciate small business owners uh you
have no idea what it's like to own a
small business why do I say that I don't
own a small business I'm an entrepreneur
I'm not an entrepreneur there's a
difference I've always been the number
two guy or the top sales guy I'm never
the guy putting down the capital taking
on the risk okay to do that and we and
listen all the guys we meet here at
Value tainment everyone at the Vault
everyone at pbd Consulting at B David
Consulting you have no idea how much
respect I have for these guys they lay
it all in the line they bust their ass
they work their tail off to create jobs
in America what percentage of jobs
created in America are uh created by
small business I think it's like 50%
right it's even higher than that Tom we
can pull that up I think there's 33
million small businesses America that
employ well over 60 million Americans an
these are job creators these are
Hustlers they are entrepreneurs they
stay up at night they're working their
freaking tail off they're trying to do
something there it is 33 million of
small businesses in America Dam turns
out I know what I'm talking about these
guys are what makes America tick I'm not
talking about the S&P 100 the S&P 500
these guys are not small businesses
these guys all have what how many
employees is it considered to be a large
business 5,000 employees whatever the
number is I'm talking about the guys
with three employees the guys with 10
employees the guys with employees the
the solo preneur just trying to create a
a job and get it off the ground I have
so much respect for these people and you
know what percentage of small businesses
fail what is it 75% within the first
five years these guys are Hustlers and
they're doing what they got to do to
feed their family to to to make their
legacy to make their impact on the world
just want to give a shout out to the
small business owners and the
entrepreneurs have they ever did I mean
Co set this off for them to start
failing horribly right Tom like
especially and and and overwhelm in
percent of it I think like 40% of the
failures were restaurants which was the
mom and pop restaurants who got shut
down and didn't have the didn't they not
like Cheesecake Factory oh I'm a chain
I'm just going to do delivery I'm going
to do all this they didn't have the
ability to do that one of the biggest
ways I support Adam 100% what he just
said I Echo that that feeling and one of
the best ways you can support small
business in your community find the
small restaurants that are that are
usually and by the way you're usually
going to find great food and you're
going to find great food from different
places all over the world where they're
operating in in your town and that's one
way you can support small businesses is
find the small restaurant that's doing
it I love Miami and I will plug at
Espanola I love going down that little
Street Espanola Way baby yep I love that
little street they're all independent
businesses what Tom saying espanol is
the whitest thing ever I love ESP espol
you know what Tom made me think about
every time Tom comes over Tom talks to
Mela and he he talks Melville in Spanish
and I swear every time Melville comes to
me afterward saying why does this sceno
try to talk to me
Spanish
Mel freaked her
out like Mel just he's he's he's making
an effort doing I I freaked her out I
tried to say good morning apparently I
said there's a demon in the
pool the cheese is old and mold so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right
here